okay let's get into this week's hatred
mail we have a brand new very topical
hatred mail intro take a listen to this
we're getting to the oranges of this
investigation so god bless United States
America Patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom okay so this week's
hatred mail once again anti-semitism
virulent anger and all of the stuff that
we've come to expect and are very
accustomed to at this point quite
frankly from hatred mail take a listen
tax cut leads to more Jew gold for David
David you are either a self-hating white
man so you are a traitor or you are a
Jew either one you are wrong and part of
the problem bethe David [ __ ] I know
David will end up supporting Cory Booker
because he is [ __ ] they are definitely
wrong about the Cory Booker thing but at
least I can work with it like no
normally the criticisms in hatred mail
are so amorphous and vague that it's
hard to even respond to them I can
assure you I am most definitely not
voting for Cory Booker and no one who
has watched more than a few minutes of
this program related to the 2020
Democratic primaries could honestly and
sincerely come away with that impression
he is not on my top three Cory Booker is
not on my top five and I guess I'd have
to think about exactly where he ranks
for me but no the the hatred is wrong
there's no chance I'm going to end up
supporting Cory Booker in 2020 send a
message of disdain to the hey treats you
can use the coupon code hey tree at
forty when you sign up at wwe.com the
coupon code hey tree at forty will save
you forty percent off of your membership
and hey tree it's cry
every time that that's used it is
spelled h80
our IOT